[Music]
hey you guys I'm Katie Kraus and can I
just say Selena Gomez looks amazing in
the April 2017 issue of vote I went
through and pulled all her best quotes
from the interview as starting with this
one about taking photos with young fans
some think that she might have taken a
dig at Justin Bieber's quote I have a
hard time saying no to children and
somebody I used to hang out with would
always get very frustrated with me just
hanging out with these kids it makes you
really write your life she dodges
questions about her new man the weekend
explaining things that she said about
her past relationships have come back to
bite her what I love what I do and I'm
aware of how lucky I am but I just
really can't wait for people to forget
about me can't keep my hands to myself
the 24 year olds also gets candid about
the toll taurine takes on you quote my
self-esteem was shot I was depressed
anxious I started to have panic attacks
right before getting on stage or right
after leaving the stage she checked into
treatment last fall for her lupus
diagnosis and since has done a life 180
she's living out of an airbnb and says
quote I think 17 people have my phone
number right now maybe two are famous
it's hard and finally here's what she
said about becoming the most followed
person on Instagram I sort of freaked
out I always end up feeling like when I
look at Instagram which is why I'm kind
of under the radar ghosting in a bit you
social media as much as its blessing and
it's fun it it can really tear people
down and I always hope that the people
I'm involved with or support me can just
kind of spread love with them up
[Music]